Speaker 1: Mitt Romney was asked the other
day, will you vote for Trump if he's the 2024
Republican nominee?
This is an interesting question because there
are many Republicans who are starting to say
things like, I would rather a different nominee.
I would prefer that we just nominate someone
different and that it not be up to me to decide
on Election Day.
Do I vote for Trump or not?
Let's just pick a different nominee.
Mitt Romney is speaking with a clarity that
many Republicans are not speaking with.
Now, this is not a look at how great Mitt
Romney is story.
This is a look at how low the bar is story.
Mitt Romney is clearly saying I would not
support Trump even if he were the nominee
in 2024.
Speaker 3: It's going to be hard to knock
him off as our nominee.
If he became a nominee, I think he loses again.
Speaker 4: And would you support him if he's
the nominee?
Speaker 3: Absolutely not.
And I mean, I get asked that.
I mean.
Speaker 2: Look.
Speaker 3: I voted to remove him from office
twice, so.
Speaker 4: I knew what your answer is going
to be had I had.
Speaker 3: But the answer is and it's not
just because he he loses.
I mean, that's that's my reason that I offer
to other people who are big fans of his.
But but it's also he's he's simply not a person
who ought to have the reigns of the government,
the United States.
Speaker 1: Okay.
Very, very clear.
Romney says it's not just about I'd rather
a different nominee.
If he's the nominee, I'm not voting for him.
Compare and contrast this with some of the
more spineless people in the Republican Party.
William Barr.
William Barr, one of Trump's former attorney
generals attorneys general, said this guy
was a threat to democracy, all these horrible,
horrible things.
But I don't know.
I mean, if he's a Democrat, I might still
have to vote for him.
Listen to this.
Speaker 5: Well, I certainly have made it
clear I don't think he should be our nominee.
And I'm going to, you know, support somebody
else for the nominee.
Speaker 4: But if he is the nominee and you
have your choices, Donald Trump or whoever
is running on the Democratic side, would you
vote for him?
Speaker 5: Because I believe that the greatest
threat to the country is the progressive agenda
being pushed by the Democratic Party.
It's inconceivable to me that I wouldn't vote
for the Republican nominee.
Speaker 2: Wow.
Speaker 1: Wow.
Threat to democracy.
Dangerous.
No business has no clue what's going on.
But I mean a savannah, please.
A Democrat.
I'm not going to vote for a Democrat.
That would be even worse.
And then Mitch McConnell, even who Trump has
called his wife, I don't remember if Trump
called his wife ugly, but he certainly called
her different names, has attacked him as a
rhino just up and down, slamming McConnell.
Even McConnell, what was it, ten days ago
when he was asked?
He played coy with it and didn't rule it out.
Speaker 2: In light of what you said, that
there's no room in your party for anyone who
covers these, I submit to you, if Donald Trump
wins the Republican nomination, would you
support him?
Speaker 6: Look, let me just say again, there
is simply no room in the Republican Party
for anti-Semitism or white supremacy, and
that would apply to all of the leaders in
the party who will be seeking office.
Speaker 1: There you go.
So even Mitch McConnell not ruling it out,
the bar is very low.
And Mitt Romney has exceeded that bar.
Make sure that you are subscribed to the David
Pakman show youtube channel.
It is free.
Unlike with voting in elections.
If you have five Google accounts, you can
subscribe five times to the YouTube channel
and I encourage you to do it.
Let's get to the 2 million.
We'll take a quick break and be right back.
The David Pakman Show does depend truly on
the support of our viewers and listeners through
the membership program.
Now there is a particular person.
His name is Alex Jones.
He hates the entire membership thing.
Speaker 2: Oh, the bonus show where you want
to make money.
Yeah.
Everybody else that makes money to fund themselves
is bad.
Speaker 1: I consider it an endorsement that
Alex Jones hates it and I encourage you to
sign up at join Packman dot com.